hey hey keep her here hey uh we just
wanted to thank you guys so much for
sticking with us these last four seasons
it's been so amazing I love you we love
you so much we love Nickelodeon somewhat
everything that's a chance to make the
show and of course this or no would not
accept idols without the brilliant minds
of Mike and Brian we love you thank you
guys you know one of the great things
about what Mike Mike and Brian do at
Comic Cons is they show you a lot of
behind the scenes stuff on the animation
side what we felt like we wanted to do
is show you what it's like for us as
actors to prepare so we shot some
footage of us getting ready and we
wanted to share it with you this is my
Perlas con thank you so much we love you
love it's a day in your life thank you
let's do this leave it in the booth
watch her watch her I love you oppa oppa
hope one two three
all right car car or rah-rah car car or
RUP RUP right be with us right be with
us break be with us CUH CUH or rah rah
right give us strength right give us
strength right give us rain kah kah rah
rah
this will be mine rah rah ha ha
is that a duck this is I should not have
to do this myself make up Janet
we're not on camera ok but I just need
to make sure that you know I it's been
four years we're not on camera all right
you know what I just need one more thing
to kind of kind of get into it a little
bit
Oh another job I know what are you doing
man uh you know well coming to an end
here write a show Nickelodeon my value
oh hey Janet yeah did you uh did you did
you need some headphones oh sure oh
thanks yeah
did you okay I was just seeing it no
sure sure sure sure sure
Kids Choice Award your morning kid toys
award you're mine I'm not gonna David
gave you
Jana can have because she's really nice
she cares about kids hey honey how are
ya
how's your day going right cool janet
has a lot of cry scenes here today that
what do you think she's gonna do to get
ready
you know Janet you can crank you and so
the boy cut down her trunk sailed away
and the tree was happy but not really
[Music]
okay good regarde
yeah I know
[Music]